Speaker 1: . OK, let's get into audience questions
for the week, first question, one that came
up indirectly a lot of times throughout stories
we talked about this week.
Is there anything at this point that convinced
that would convince Trump that Donald Trump
actually lost?
We are more than six months out.
There's a so-called election audit happening
in Arizona.
They're looking for bamboo fibers as evidence
that the ballots were dumped from China.
It's crazy what's going on.
So the question is a different one now, six
months out than it was six months ago.
Six months ago, we could have accurately said
after these various efforts failed to demonstrate
that there was fraud.
As Donald Trump says, some of these Trump
is will become convinced.
They will accept that Donald Trump really
did lose and some did.
The percentage of Republicans that believe
Trump won has declined over the last couple
of months.
But it's still really, really high.
And at this point, I don't believe there is
anything that would convince these Trump is
that Donald Trump really just lost.
It wasn't stolen.
It wasn't an illegitimate win by Joe Biden
or whatever.
He just lost.
And there's two things that are going on.
No.
One, at this point, you know, we think of
the holy grail of the mayor culpa, which would
be Trump coming to them and saying, sirs,
I lost.
That's it, even if he were to do that.
They still wouldn't believe it.
They would say they would do what's called
the special pleading, they would say, well,
Trump says he lost now, but because he's been
forced to say it, the deep state or Joe Biden
threatened him with house arrest or they got
to him.
And it's not even you.
We can't even believe Donald Trump when he
says this at this point in time.
That's one possibility.
Now, if you believe Trump to be the epitome
of the alpha male, the idea that he would
be successfully blackmailed by someone as
weak as they see Joe Biden being, that also
doesn't make sense.
But remember, none of this makes sense.
So I think even if Trump said.
I was wrong, I lost they those who still believe
Trump actually won would just say, clearly,
somebody forced Trump to do that.
Number two, we don't really even need to theorize
or speculate because for a year, Trump said
the virus isn't serious and we're winning.
And it's like the flu and we don't need to
worry about anything.
And it developed this huge anti vaccine sentiment
on the right.
And then Trump was secretly vaccinated in
January at the White House, didn't tell anybody
until he was asked about it months later and
said, yeah, people people should get it.
And Republicans are still the most anti Kovik
vaccine group out there.
It was too late after feeding them the misinformation
for months and months, really over a year
about the virus.
By the time Trump simply said, yeah, I got
the vaccine and people should get it, it was
too late to even convince them.
So once an idea has spread virally in the
minds of these Trump, even Trump himself can't
change their minds.
That's how powerful these viral memes of disinformation
have become.
Now, last thing, earlier in the week, I talked
about anecdotal thinking.
A lot of the many of these Trump ists believe
Biden didn't really when he's not legitimate
and these types of things because of the things
that Donald Trump said for so long.
But there are other Trump ists who aren't
able to get beyond anecdotal thinking.
And what I mean by that is even though we
can go and say, OK, Trump got lots of votes,
but so did Joe Biden and it was just record
turnout.
And we understand why it makes sense.
Pandemic and one of the biggest sort of adjudications
of a of a White House presidential term.
And who knows how long makes sense.
There would be a lot of votes for a lot of
these people.
It's just anecdotal thinking.
Like I live in wherever Mississipi.
Everybody I know voted for Trump.
I don't know anybody who voted for Joe Biden.
Now, maybe you do, but they're scared to mention
it because you're nuts and they worry how
you would react.
But I don't know.
The people around me and my deeply conservative
enclave all all voted for Trump.
And I went to a Trump rally and it was filled
with Trump people.
And I watched Fox News and they went to a
diner and everybody at the diner seemed to
like Trump.
My anecdotal thinking is informing and superseding
my views, superseding the the empirical, broad
strokes, views of polling and the fact that
you don't hear from most people on Twitter,
you know, no.
No one place is going to tell you sort of
what the sentiment is of a country with three
hundred and thirty one million people.
So that's another piece of it.
And then there's people who are just every
combination of the above or bad faith actors
or just suffering from a cognitive issue.
So, no, sadly, at this point in time, if you
still believe that Donald Trump actually won,
I don't believe there's anything left that
could convince you other than just time, over
time.
Maybe some of these people will be able to
reexamine their beliefs about the 2020 election
with some distance and objectivity.
But beyond that, I don't have high hopes that
we're going to convince these people, nor
do I think that we should be employing a retail
strategy of arguing with individuals to try
to do it.
I think the way to win elections is let's
get turnout up, let's prevent voter suppression
rather than arguing with individual Trump.